Hi, welcome back. In the last session,
we introduced the idea that knowing
what's happened in the past in terms of
prices for individual stock or markets
can help you predict sometimes what will
happen the next day, the next week, the
next 6 months. This session, I want to
build on that theme and talk a little
bit more about price patterns we've been
able to see over time, especially as
they relate to things we can observe,
what month of the year it is, what day
of the week it is, what time of the day
it is. In particular, there are three
effects that academics in particular
have chronicled but practitioners have
also noticed. The first is called the
January effect that January tend to be
the best month of the year to invest in
and what happens in January is often a
good predictor of what the year will
deliver. The second is called the
weekend effect which is in pretty much
every year in the last century. Mondays
have been much better much worse days to
invest in than any other days of the
work. There's a Monday effect and the
question is why? Why are Mondays such
terrible days to invest in markets? And
the third is and this is a weaker
effect. There is some evidence that mid
trading day there is a swoon in prices
and there seems to be some some
recovery. I'm not sure any of these
temporal irregularities, as I'm going to
call them, are a basis for making money,
but they exist. And might as well look
at why they exist, because there might
be clues on price patterns from what you
can find. First, let's start with the
January effect. Going back to 1927,
I looked at average returns by month,
January through December from 1927
through 2024.
take a look at the returns and it's kind
of a no contest, right? The best month
of the year by far over the last century
for US stocks has been January. Now,
before you get too excited though, if
you look at the difference in returns,
it looks big on a chart, right? But it's
3% versus 1%, but that's still pretty
significant on a monthly basis. Now if
you want to have a different way of
examining this and this is for a shorter
time but 1926 to 2018.
If you look at just January returns
broken down by market cap desert from
smallest to largest. You can see the
January effect is almost entirely a
small cap effect. In fact with large
companies there is no January effect.
So, not only is there a January effect,
but it's a effect that seems to be
isolated to the smallest companies in
the market
and it's strong across countries. If you
look across every country, there's a
January effect in pretty much every
country. So, let's summarize. There's a
January effect. It seems to be strongest
for small companies and it's across
markets. It's not something that is
specific to the US market. What are the
possible explanations?
People have tried several. None of them
fully fit, but you can maybe the there's
all all of them put together can explain
it. One is there's some fund flows.
People sending money in December into
mutual funds and that money being
invested in January. Maybe there's a
fund flow effect where there's far more
money flowing into stocks in January
than any other month of the year. The
second could be window dressing by
institutions. They're trying to get rid
of their losers the end of December. So
they look good on December 31st and they
buy them back in January. But if that's
the case, the January effect should be
strongest in money losing stocks and in
money making stocks. And the evidence
for that is weak. It could be tax
selling. Investors sell stocks in
December to to to manage their taxes and
they buy back in January. None of these
fully fit, but they might all contribute
to understanding the January effect. The
troubling thing is the fact that it's
strongest for small cap stock suggests
that whatever the effect is has
something to do with market size as well
that the that whatever the factors that
cause the generary effect is greater for
smaller companies than for larger
companies
effect it exists and as an investor what
can I do about it say fully invest in
January to begin with but by itself
knowing what's happened in January
doesn't help you that much over the rest
of the year Because once January is
behind you, the rest of the year look
pretty much alike for every single year.
Let's look at the weekend effect. This
graph I've looked at returns by day of
the week. Monday through Friday. And
again, the standout is Monday. Mondays
historically have been the worst day of
the week to invest in US stocks and
Fridays have been the best days. Now,
let's dig a little deeper. That weekend
effect is not just again in the US. It
shows up in pretty much every market.
There is a weekend effect stronger in
some markets than others. The
Philippines, for instance, weekend
effect shows up as a smaller positive
return on Monday than other days of the
week. But clearly, Mondays lag every
other day of the week. And if you look
at the US across time, an interesting
phenomenon has popped up. Well, in every
single time period, Mondays have been
the worst day of the week to invest in
1981 through 90 91 through No, there
have been sub periods where that's not
been true. 91 through 2000, for
instance,
Mondays were the best day of the week to
invest in. I don't know what happened
during that time period, but that was
the dotcom boom. Again, 2021 through 21
again a good period for US stocks.
Mondays have been a good day of, you
know, the week to invest in. So the
Monday effect to the extent that it's
been around shows up in very long time
periods, but there have been sub periods
where it hasn't held up. So let's look
at possible explanations. Again, the
Monday effect is really not a Monday
effect. It's a weekend effect. And
here's what what what I mean by a
weekend effect. That negative return you
see on Monday isn't because of stocks
doing badly over the course of the
trading day on Monday. It's because they
open clo on Monday. There's some argue
that it's because bad news comes out
over the weekend. And there's some
evidence that companies try to manage
news to come out over the weekend. But
if that's the case, you should be able
to exploit it, right? Because if you
know this happens systematically, you
should be able to sell short on Friday
and collect your money on Monday. And
there's no evidence that makes money for
anybody. The weekend effect has become
weaker over time. And maybe there's some
some explanation there. Maybe the fact
that we can now trade in most things 24
hours a day, 7 days a week is kind of
taking away the weekend effect. But
there is that weekend effect. It might
not be again the basis for somebody
trying to make money, but it might
become the basis for you timing when you
buy a stock. You might choose to buy it.
If you have a stock that's undervalued
that you've decided to buy and it's
Thursday, you know, you might not buy it
that Thursday or Friday. You might wait
till Monday morning and buy it because
then to the extent that there's a Monday
effect, you might get it at a lower
price. So you might incorporate it into
some other investment philosophy. But as
a standalone philosophy, it's probably
not going to make you money intraday.
Again, if you break down trading days,
there is some evidence that returns are
different by for different parts of the
day. Who knows why? And to the and this
is truly a phenomenon, but there's not
much. It's purely for cocktail parties.
You can talk about a midday soon, but
it's not something you can take
advantage of as a trader to make money.
So across months, across days, even
within days, there's a price pattern.
Now, if you look at the interaction
between price patterns and trading
volume, there seems to be an
interaction. High volume stocks, there's
a much bigger difference in price
momentum effect between winners and
losers than in low volume stocks. So
momentum tends to get stronger when
volume is high than when volume is low.
Something to factor in. So what's the
bottom line? There are time patterns in
stock prices, right? January's, Mondays,
intraday, the midday soon. But making
money on these time patterns, it's very
difficult to do. I can't think of a
single investor who became successful
over time trying to take advantage of
just time patterns. But you might be
able to incorporate those time patterns
as I mentioned into your investment
philosophy. So you might want to buy
your stocks towards the very end of
December so you can take advantage of
the January effect rather than at the
end of January. So those are things you
might build into a traditional
investment philosophy as an add-on as an
augmentation but not as a standalone.
I hope you found the session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.